à paris ou dans sa région il est
impossible de les rater quand ils se
déploient les gilets violets ce sont
leurs surnoms il s'agit en fait des
volontaires du tourisme ils sont 600
déployés cet été en ile de france
leur mission guider et accueillir les
touristes étrangers à proximité des
lieux emblématiques de la région
ils sont là pour accueillir pour
souhaiter la bienvenue aux visiteurs
quels qu'ils soient franciliens
européens et mondiaux et de manière à ce
que les gens se sentent un peu moins
seul depuis son lancement en décembre
2016 l'opération des volontaires du
tourisme a profité à plus de 1500 jeunes
pour la plupart des étudiants en
tourisme qui tirent profit de
l'affluence des vacances pour accumuler
une précieuse expérience professionnelle
c'est un secteur que j'ai tout j'ai aimé
et ça fait pas si on fait deux matches
de ma formation puisque je suis en école
de commerce non je pense que c'est une
belle opportunité représente la ville de
paris donc franchement c'est plutôt une
responsabilité
après une année 2010 est record pour le
secteur touristique les professionnels
espèrent un crue similaire cette année
pour amplifier son soutien la région
lancera également à la rentrée un pass
spécial où pourront s'accumuler offre
pour les transports et visites pour les
sites franciliens
nous voulons avoir le maximum de
partenaires sur se passe de façon à
éviter de devoir transporter sa carte
bleue du liquide sur soi
ce qui évidemment est source de
pickpockets d'insécurité donc impasse
très simple très rapide pour les
transports pour les musées l'an passé 48
millions de touristes ont visité l'île
de france l'année 2018 pourrait pâtir
des mouvements sociaux s'il se prolonge
tout l'été